fait sur le terrain une équipe d'antenne
2 essayer de voir comment la loi de 1983
loi sur l'égalité des femmes étaient
appliquées 18 entreprises en france
l'appliquent parmi elles moulinex il
faut dire que 67 % de l'effectif est
constituée de femmes et que 80% d'entre
elles travaillent à la chaîne en quête
de françois jeunes ces gestes saccadés
répétitif plus de 4000 femmes les
exécute chaque jour chez moulinex avec
le premier plan d'égalité
professionnelle lancé en 1984 une
centaine d'entre elles ont échappé au
travail à la chaîne aujourd'hui après
deux ans de formation elle travaille au
contrôle de la production au réglage des
machines et même dans les bureaux
d'études mais à 33 ou 34 ans retournée à
l'école n'a pas été facile
moi j'avais un peu peur de ne pas
réussir
cette formation parce que fall et
retourne à l'école ça faisait 15 ans que
je n'étais pas retourné donc j'avais
peur d'avoir des difficultés sur
certains niveaux quoi mais ces femmes
sont allés jusqu'au bout de leurs
efforts à 98% elles ont réussi leur cap2
mécanique d'entretien aujourd'hui dans
leur nouvelle tâche elles sont mieux
payés et surtout elle trouve dans leur
travail un véritable intérêt donc on a
une vision du travail quand même
totalement différent de mettre une
plaque et trois vices avons cherché pas
vraiment à quoi ça servait que
maintenant bon - cherchent à s'enrichir
de plus en plus quoi on évolue cette
évolution n'est pas seulement
professionnelle ces femmes mères de
famille suivent désormais plus
facilement la scolarité de leurs enfants
cela me permet de pouvoir
rêver dans leur femme a fait une
révision de toutes les matières sèches
dans le par au fond de classe dans le
manager france faute pas
la formation de ces 100 femmes a coûté
10 millions de francs à moulinet l'état
y est allé de sa poche en finançant 30%
de l'opération enfin la requalification
de ces ouvrières permet à l'entreprise
d'être plus compétitif
un tiers du personnel féminin de
production
devra passer l'information d'ici fin
très vite ça doit nous permettre de
préparer les gens aux changements aux
évolutions de l'entreprise notamment la
polyvalence un extension des tâches et à
la mobilité
dans toute la france seuls 18
entreprises se sont lancées dans ses
plans d'égalité professionnelle
une avancée qui reste somme toute bien
modeste